est-ce que tu crois que les gens savent
ce que tu es devenu
c'est à dire les gens qui t'ont vu n'ont
pas à l'époque dans des salles x parce
que ils sont surtout vu sur canal ou
dans des cassettes vidéos est-ce que tu
crois que les gens aujourd'hui savent ce
que tu es devenu ce que je suis devenu
une personne qui vit avec ses chevaux à
100 km de Paris qui fait du théâtre tous
les soirs je crois que maintenant les
gens commencent à commencer à savoir
on a demandé à Laurent ma fille que tu
connais on lui a dit tiens Laurent tu
vas aller dans la rue tu vas poser des
questions genre tu vas leur demander si
ça ce que devenu
costard de star
voilà vous connaissez Brigitte Lahaie
Brigitte Lahaie et ben c'est la femme de
Jean-Luc Lahaye non le chanteur vous
connaissez Brigitte
une actrice
une actrice de films porno je crois
quand même
et qu'est-ce qu'elle est devenue
aujourd'hui aucune idée aucune idée ça
va pas être bien brillant mais je sais
pas trop elle fait plus de télé elle
couche plus j'en sais rien elle a été
nommée ce matin secrétaire d'État elle a
jamais sur le sport
non vous plaisantez pas du tout c'est
tombé ce matin vu comme va la France ça
m'étonne en guerre quoi c'est tout à
fait possible mais si connait un sport
au lit au
lits les matins et devant des poireaux
sur les marchés aujourd'hui vous le
saviez non du tout ça vous étonne
vous voyez il y a pas de souci non mais
vous trouvez que c'est la suite logique
de ce qu'elle faisait avant alors pas du
tout parce qu'elle est toujours dans le
poireau
aujourd'hui elle est rentrée dans les
ordres elle est religieuse sans un
couvent dans le Lot et elle s'appelle
soeur Brigitte sans blague un costume de
religieuse vous pensez qu'elle pourrait
vous donner encore des idées ah oui
certainement c'était quand même belle
femme c'était une belle fille ça il y a
pas ça il m'est arrivé de révéler le
même
vous savez ce qu'elle est devenue
aujourd'hui non pas du tout non mais ce
matin ministre de la condition féminine
oh c'est super pourquoi pas après tout
pour moi c'est une [ __ ] enfin disons
qu'elle a fait des films porno
aujourd'hui elle est ministre alors si
vous la croisez demain vous allez
l'appeler madame la ministre ou vieille
[ __ ]
aujourd'hui depuis ce matin c'est pas
possible depuis ce matin
[Musique]
pas un conseil des ministres habillé
c'est vrai mais avec tout ce qu'elle a
fait bon suite à son passé je crois pas
je pense pas hein vous savez de toute
façon qui est bibouara même tout est
même si elle est devenue ministre jeudi
si elle est de gauche Kiabi moi qui a vu
hein j'attendais à sa personne à elle
parce que ça subordonne tout un cursus
de carrière qui est pas sans
arrière-pensée ce qui fait que vous êtes
une bande de pornographe et de
dégueulasse
merci beaucoup monsieur voilà alors ça
vous pouvez passer merci infiniment
il y a une chose qui est certaine c'est
quand on leur dit que tu as été nommé
ministre de la condition féminine ou
quoi les gens sont pas spécialement
étonnés tu vois comme quoi notre époque
qui est encore du pain sur la planche
c'était ministre de l'intérieur mais bon
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu